you probably already know this but games
are hard to make and often
don't always get released with their
original vision intact
from a gameplay pivot here to a
character swap there
most go through some pretty big changes
throughout their development
but then there are some games that
change course completely
here are seven games you might not know
were originally
something else entirely hot off the
heels of releasing prince of persia
signs of time
in 2003 the team at ubisoft montreal was
tasked with making a follow-up for the
xbox 360 and playstation 3.
according to director patrice desolay
the team's mandate was to
redefine the action adventure genre
which was no mean feat
the original vision for the game was to
take the parkour gameplay from prince
and put it into an open world the move
to next gen also enabled the team to put
cut ideas from sands of time
into the game including crowds and the
ability to jump from rooftop to rooftop
over the course of development desolate
came to realize that a prince
wasn't exactly an exciting character to
play as
quote i wanted the prince to have a
different job than just being there
waiting for mom and dad to die and take
their place
during his research he uncovered a book
about secret societies
and one that caught his eye was the
assassins and so the player would play
as an assassin
protecting an ai controlled prince the
project was originally titled prince of
persia assassins
but as desolate and the team
incorporated more of the secret society
stuff
the prince eventually ended up being cut
it wasn't until gdc 2006 that ubisoft
marketing suggested the title we've all
come to know and love
assassin's creed halo may have redefined
the console first person shooter but
originally
it was not first person at all or even a
shooter
or even a console game halo originally
started life as an isometric real-time
strategy game
more in line with bungie's previous
franchise myth the game eventually
changed to a third person perspective
when the developers realized that it was
more fun to actually control the game's
vehicles
than letting the computer do it the game
was unveiled at mac world in 1999 by
none other than steve
jobs but after some financial
difficulties bungie ended up being
bought by microsoft a year later
and halo was being shaped to be the
upcoming xbox consoles flagship game
halo's perspective changed once again
this time to first person
and the story and world was cemented the
rest as they say is history
if you want the full story check out our
episode of remember when
all about the game's origin look i could
do
a whole video about the tumultuous
development of resident evil 4.
at least four versions of that game were
conceptualized and then ultimately
scrapped
but let's focus on the version that
eventually became devil may cry
early in development resident evil 4 was
in the hands of resident evil 2 director
hideki kamia
who wanted to make resident evil a
little cooler
time to go to work guys
the protagonist tony was originally a
superhuman upgraded by biotechnology
resident evil series producer shinji
mikami felt that the coolness angle
didn't really fit with the resident evil
franchise and so the game was spun off
and became its own thing this one's
pretty well known but a very cool story
nonetheless
back in the early 80s nintendo was
struggling to break into the american
market
and had thousands of unsold arcade
machines that needed to be salvaged
a young designer by the name of shigeru
miyamoto was brought on to create a game
that could hopefully sell these cabinets
to try and be more appealing to the
american audience
nintendo attempted to get the license
for popeye but when that all fell
through
mimoto apes the love triangle between
bluto olive oil and popeye with
donkey kong a carpenter who would
eventually become mario and his
girlfriend
pauline
[Music]
splinter cell started life by being
shuffled around various ubisoft studios
in paris it was an rts game upon landing
in new york it became an action
adventure title called the drift
where the world's major cities were
floating around in the sky on
islands playing as buster these are my
awards mother
from army no not that one you could
control flying vehicles and the game's
ai meant that crowds would react
appropriately
to your actions it also had a modular
weapon that could allow players to
grapple up walls
the drift sadly was going nowhere and
ubisoft eventually tried to pitch it as
a james bond game
but it didn't get picked up eventually
the project made its way to montreal and
was to be the metal gear solid 2
killer ubisoft's idea was to get one
over on metal gear by attaching tom
clancy's name
and releasing on the platform that metal
gear wasn't available on
microsoft quickly bought onto the idea
and helped optimize and market the game
this video you're looking at right now
is what borderlands
used to be gone is the colorful
cel-shaded art style and wacky humor and
what we originally had instead was
a pretty po-faced sci-fi title the
original pitch was halo
meets diablo and the game's artists were
given inspiration words like
serious gritty and realistic
however testers within gearbox deemed
the game's art style to be too similar
to fallout 3 and there was a huge
discrepancy
between the game's realistic look and
its bombastic
over-the-top gameplay at the 11th hour
the developer changed the art style to
what we recognized today
bioshock is such an impactful and
memorable game it's hard to think that
it might have been
completely different in the original
pitch you were to take on the role of
carlos coelho
a deprogrammer assigned to infiltrate a
religious cult called serene dawn
and rescue a wealthy heiress the player
was able to create
any weapon they wanted from a set of
attributes and components
and modify them at will there was
definitely hacking aplenty in bioshock
but the original plans were much
grander you would be able to hack the
environment increasing and decreasing
oxygen levels
manipulate gravity electrify flaws and
even adjust the temperature
instead of attacking splices the enemy
types would be human cultists
cyborg killers genetically engineered
mammal aquatic hybrids
and robots it also had grand ideas for a
multiplayer component
where you'd play as the enemy monster in
someone else's story mode
irrational games released their old
design documents online if you want to
go back
and see the bioshock that might have
been those are seven games that were
originally something else entirely
come find me on twitter and talk to me
about bioshock i'm at lucy james games
we'll see you next time
you